We've successfully created company culture revolving around innovation, new functionality, and tackling new challenges.
We are the company operating the real estate information site LIFULL HOME'S.
Users looking to move house show a trend for short periods of focused searching.
We receive most inquiries from our landing pages for PC or mobile browsers.
and less from our smartphone app.
But I think apps allow for higher frequency, deeper communication.
Our mission is to increase the volume of inquiries we receive through our app.
That's why we've focused on "users first" and "user happiness."
Our aim is to develop an app that will meet user expectations.
In order to achieve this, listening to our users is vital.
So we started to reply to every review we receive.
Three staff members take it in turns.
Making things more personal lets users see the people behind the curtain.
We conduct a survey and use the results to help improve the app's bottlenecks.
Then we run an A/B test with 50% of our subjects.
If it goes well, we try it with 100%.
Introducing bottom navigation was very divisive inside the company.
Thinking of user convenience, however, I very much wanted to introduce it.
So we used Firebase Remote Config to hold an A/B test.
User response was positive, allowing us to confirm its viability and adopt it.
One KPI we looked at closely
was the overall app conversion rate.
Introducing bottom navigation upped conversion rate by 1.5 times
and also allowed us to improve the main screen utilization rate.
LIFULL HOME'S users have a clear goal.
An intuitive design,good structure
and even engineering are already defined in Material Design.
Everyone on our team agreed this really worked for us.
We develop with the mindset of "putting the user first."
We used the A/B test function from the Developer Console
to perform A/B tests for the Store's screenshots and app launcher icon.
This has led to an 188% improvement in user install rates.
The numbers confirm that our user-focused approach is effective.
Our internal KPI was user inquiries via the app, and the number increased 166% over last year
and our rating on the Play Store increased from 3.5 to 4.2.
We are incredibly grateful for the user feedback we have been receiving.
We look forward to continuing our work on new Google platforms
and bringing innovative services to the industry.